how is it that thousands potentially
tens of thousands of people
were unnecessarily exposed to covid19 it
is
a staggering story and at the heart of
it is this a computer error
message that might seem improbable but
believe me
this is all true and it turns out that
you know if we look back at the
architecture of the testing system
we can see what's gone wrong so these
boxes here you don't really need to know
about what's
what's in them but all you need to know
is that these green boxes are millions
of people being tested for covet across
the country the information goes through
to the blue boxes that's the contact
traces so ensuring
that any of those outbreaks are clamped
down on and in the middle of it
is public health england so it's kind of
like the gateway for all of this data
i'll just do a slightly more simplified
version of that so public health england
in the middle
test results go through into test and
trace and
that's been working relatively well so
far and partly because they've got an
existing database to deal with this
stuff so
you've got those kind of nhs labs around
the country most of the ones in
hospitals
they automatically pump all of these
results through to public health england
that automatically goes through
to test and trace that's how it works
but here's the thing a lot of tests are
not done by these
nhs hospital labs they're done these
days by something called pillar two now
these are the new labs those centralized
ones
run by serco deloitte and so on
lighthouse labs
and they don't have a direct route
through to this database
so here's where the problem comes in
they've had to jerry rig the system
instead
they're kind of uploading csv is a type
of spreadsheet
through to a computer in public health
england running excel
which then pumps them out down that
highway
but i should say at this stage you
really should never do that you should
never use excel as a database management
tool
and we're about to understand why
because in public health england it
turns out the version of excel they were
running
is old it's an old version of excel and
it has this limit on how much data you
can actually put
into it a 65 000 row limit sounds like a
lot but actually think about
it the cases have been getting more and
more over the course of the last
few weeks and it turns out that it broke
through
that limit they got the computer error
message and as a result
thousands of cases weren't pushed
through to test and trace until they
discovered about this
uh just on friday and it does somewhat
change our picture of this disease
in the country this is what we thought
was happening to cases uh over the
course of the last few months and now
we've had this big influx
of new data and a lot of that should be
said as a backlog from previous days but
it looks like a scary chart though
but it's worth asking does it mean that
that's a patrick valance illustration we
heard about a couple of weeks ago
is more likely to happen you remember
the one the one that showed the cases
might go up and up and up if we didn't
clamp down on them well here's what's
happened uh as far as we knew it before
the weekend so this is what happened to
cases
uh before the weekend now we've got
revised numbers you can see the line is
a bit steeper
but it's still nowhere near the kind of
doubling every seven days that we saw
into bacteria balances illustration it's
more like doubling every 11 to 12 days
even so though even if this doesn't
radically change the picture
of this disease in the uk it is still
striking that a computer error of all
things
meant that thousands of people have been
exposed to this disease